Hello, my name is Zisl Slepovitch
and I'm musician-in-residence at Yale
University's Fortunoff Video Archive for
Holocaust Testimonies.
This video series is
designed as a companion
to our album Where Is Our Homeland,
which is the first volume in the archive's
ongoing effort to present songs
and poems performed
by survivors in testimonies
given to the Fortunoff Archive over
the last 40 years.
You can learn more about the project on the
archive's website,
songsfromtestimonies.org.
Where Is Our Homeland? Songs
from Testimonies, Volume
1 was recorded in 2019
by the Zisl Slepovitch Ensemble, featuring
renowned singer Sasha Lurje,
Craig Judelman on the violin, Joshua
Camp on the accordion,
keyboards and guitar,
Dmitry Ishenko on the bass, and myself
on woodwinds.
The songs in this
collection differ vastly in
terms of style, social and historical
background, language,
and many other aspects,
but collectively they
create a multidimensional
picture of Jewish life before
and during World War II.
We will talk about the Polish Jewish songs
that were sung by Peretz H., a Holocaust
survivor born in 1927
in Warsaw.
When war broke out, he was a little boy.
Peretz used to sing in
the streets of his home
city to earn a living and shared
several songs in his 1993
Fortunoff Video Archive testimony.
Songs of the survivors, like Peretz,
are of truly special value as
they shed a unique light on the Polish
and more specifically, Warsaw music culture
of the interwar and World War II
periods. Some of the texts, like
this one in Peretz's testimony, are
not to be found in any known sources
today.
W pociagu jest tlok, Crowded Train,
is one of at least two Polish
renditions of the popular Mexican copla
song Cielito Lindo.
Just like Walc Francois that we discussed
in the first episode, this is the song
that Peretz H.
sang in the courtyards of Warsaw,
along with many other
children like himself,
as well as local street bands, which would
have been lost to history, if not for
the testimony of Peretz H.
It refers to the depression and smuggling
of groceries in the prewar Warsaw.
In postwar Poland, the song gained
newfound popularity, thanks in
part to Leonard Buczkowsky's
1946 movie, Zakazane
piosenki, Forbidden Songs.
The new version, although similar to
the prewar version sung by Peretz,
referred to the war.
"Teraz jest wojna, kto handluje
ten zyje." It is war now.
Those who sell, live.
Decades later in 1982,
the Polish Cielito Lindo came
back to life with a new lyrics, yet
again in the wake of
the military coup d'etat.
It’s crowded on the train,
The darkness is cozy,
So the fun begins:
Someone gets
their arms entangled,
Someone is crushing the eggs,
The meat carcasses
are under the bench.
She gives him a kiss,
He lifts up her bosom,
And finds two pieces of ham.
Meat carcasses and pork chops,
Dripping from beneath the heart,
And the train is racing like crazy.
Oh, Zosha, dear,
Warsaw is so near,
Everyone will admit,
Living in Warsaw is expensive.
For you I am bringing it all.
Aunt Adela and her daughter, Fela
Always quarrel on the road.
They get on each other’s nerves,
Thinking they will return home today.
Oh, Zosha, dear,
please join me for dinner.
There will be vodka, wine
whatever you want,
The rest is up to you.
Just remembering these song so many years..
they took a common tune/melody
yes and put it (the song) inside
inside (the melody),
yes, definitely
It’s crowded on the train
The darkness is cozy,
So the fun begins:
Someone gets their arms entangled,
Someone is crushing the eggs,
The meat carcasses are under the bench.
She gives him a kiss,
He lifts up her bosom,
And finds two pieces of ham.
Meat carcasses and pork chops,
Dripping from beneath the heart,
And the train is racing like crazy.
Oh, Zosha, dear,
Warsaw is so near,
Everyone will admit,
Living in Warsaw is expensive.
For you I am bringing it all.
Oh, Zosha, dear,
Warsaw is so near,
Everyone will admit,
Living in Warsaw is expensive.
For you I am bringing it all.
Aunt Adela and her daughter, Fela
Always quarrel on the road.
They get on each other’s nerves,
Thinking they will return home today.
Oh, Zosha, dear,
please join me for dinner.
There will be vodka,
wine — whatever you want,
The rest is up to you.
Oh, Zosha, dear,
please join me for dinner.
There will be vodka,
wine — whatever you want,
The rest is up to you.
Oh, Zosha, dear,
please join me for dinner.
There will be vodka,
wine — whatever you want,
The rest is up to you.
W pociagu jest tlok, Crowded
Train.
It is a very special song
which helped people make
a living, even survive.
But the origin of this song is
not in Polish language and
not in Polish culture.
The origins comes to, back
to Latin America,
Mexico, where
it was called Cielito Lindo,
and it was a folk
song belonging to the copla genre,
and performed by
mariachi wandering bands
during that time.
And it was popularized
by the composer Quirino
Mendoza y Cortes in the late 19th century.
He used this melody for
his composition, The Wrestler,
and from that time it became
enormously popular
in Mexico, in different Spanish
culture, diasporas in the world, but very
soon also in other
cultures as well.
So the song was performed
by such famous singers
like Placido Domingo,
Luciano Pavarotti, in Poland
by famous singers
Violetta Villas or
Maryla Rodowicz,
who performed it
under the title Long Living
the Ball, or Dancing Party, which
became a very popular
song during the communist time in Poland.
But when it came
to Poland in the thirties
of the last century, via
Berlin,
and it was sang by
a famous
Chilean singer
at that time,
Rosita Serrano,
who came to Berlin
singing it,
she was called Chilean Nightingale,
a famous singer, and that, that
was the
way how it came from Berlin
to prewar Warsaw.
It was time of depression, a time
of economic crisis.
So the lyrics to this song
were in Polish, were
about smuggling groceries
in trains or trams
in Warsaw.
And this version of this song was
forgotten in, in Poland.
And I think thanks to the performance
by Mr. Peretz
in that recording, we
still can have these lyrics and this
first version of Polish
presence of, of this song
at that time.
We may call these type of songs, we
called contrafactum, which
means that there is
a substitution of one
takes to the another
without any substantial change in music,
so keep the melody and change
the lyrics according to circumstances,
historical, political,
culture circumstances.
So when war
came to Warsaw,
to Poland in
1939, the lyrics
changed and
it was mostly about
the war, "teraz jest wojna
kto handluje ten zyje." "It is war
now. Who sells,
lives."
And it was sung by
the people on the streets
who from one side, like Mr. Peretz
who wanted to survive to make their living.
From the other hand, it
was sung by people who are engaged
in underground movement.
So it was still about
smuggling, but not necessarily
groceries, also weapons and
illegal literature as well.
And because of that,
it was sometimes very dangerous to
be a singer of that songs,
because many of them belonged
to the underground movement and
took part in actions
against Nazi Germans
during the occupation
time. So we started to
call that song
Forbidden Songs.
And this is a title of a famous
movie, which was, I think
the first feature movie after the war
in Poland,
created in 1947
by the film director, a film
director, Leonard Buczkowski,
who established his
career before the war as a director
of famous war
movies. It was big budget
and, and he
cooperated after
the war with Ludwik
Starski for screenwriting, was an
author of screen writing for
this movie.
Ludwik Starski was
the father of a famous set
designer set designer Allan Starski,
who worked for many
years with Humphrey Bogart.
And he was also
awarded the Academy Award
for Schindler's
List in 1994.
So they both, Buczkowski
and Starski decided to
make a song
a hero of this
film.
So it is a plot, of course,
around it about different
underground activities in,
in Warsaw during the occupation.
But the main hero of this movie
is a song, the Forgotten Songs,
and among them,
the Crowded Train.
The communist authorities were
not satisfied with the first version
of this movie.
It was not enough for them, politically
engaged on the Soviet
side, and not enough underlying
the cruelty of
the German soldiers.
So that, after
two years they made a second version
of this movie.
And, you know, it, it,
it became a very, very
famous
film, which popular, popularizes
this song, Crowded Train again.
But this is not the end of the story.
And this song has been long living.
In fact, when we
in Poland had a so-called martial law
implemented by General Jaruzelski
on December 13,
1981,
mostly people in Poland said
there is another type of occupation.
That's the war came back
and it was a war within our
society, but
it was a good ground, a new context
for for such songs from
the war time and again
Crowded Train became very popular
at that time under, of
course, the new
title and with new lyrics now
about Green Crow,
Zielona Wrona, Wrona was an abbreviation
of the government
name, you know, in this new regime
circumstances.
So it was a new living for
that song.
And I wish
that it would be not the
end of the story.
I wish that this song will
survive in our
cultural memory in archives
and that
this will influence new
productions and performings.
But my hope is that
never again in connection
with new wars in the future.
Let's keep it for the peace time.